we don't have defects we have work we  therefore are each articulations of the  shattered Mind Of God so how do we heal  God  by healing the shattered vessels within  us and when people say oh so I found  something wrong with me I said no you  found out the nature of the Year  shattered vessels which means you still  you discovered your configuration of the  Brokenness of God  now you're called upon to work on it  when I say to people I said there's  nothing wrong with you you discovered  your work I mean that really relieves  people it takes away the shame of oh my  God this is wrong with me there's  something wrong with you you've been  avoiding your work yeah I get it let's  just get to work